and i just rock up with the the the man
and i throw the first blow and i'm like
[ __ ]
and then i'm out
in scene
that's my role in tea yeah that's what i
want and i make cake
and then all i do is complain to
duchenne
[Laughter]
like the youngers are starving yeah yeah
that's that's what i want to be having
more for you we need more food what's
going on with this connect
there's the grub yeah
we need more food in the streets the
youngers are balling
[Music]
okay while go on people what's good my
jesus thank you for showing face uh
welcome
what else is there to say
um happy for you to be here as always
guys what we're going to need you to do
is pause the episode right this second
real quick pause it head on over to
pitch
[ __ ] me
where did that come from patreon.com
forward slash shitty gigs thank you
patreon.com forward slash shits and gigs
we need to get over there and that's
going to give you
two years worth of episode two years
worth of content your boys coming up in
the game
um over there on patreon and you're
going to get a brand new episode from us
every single thursday on top of that
all the other perks you get to join in
the zoom calls with us once a month you
get discount on merch you get all the
bells and whistles priority on the
[ __ ] on topics for us to talk about
um and just a nice friendly community
um over there on patreon so patreon.com
forward slash shits and gigs head on
over there today um and have some fun
with it yeah mom
on top of that guys if you are watching
this on youtube please please do us a
massive favor
like and subscribe and hit the
notification bell so you know when we're
posting it does so much for the channel
um we're on that mission 100k now
we want that plaque baby we do want that
we're halfway
imagine seeing it here guys this is
where it's going to live when we get it
i want that 100k
subscriber plaque so flipping badly
we're over the halfway mark now so
guys tell a friend so surreal oh i know
oh i know tell a friend to tell a friend
so we can get that plaque because we've
wanted that plaque since before we even
had a youtube channel it's so cool and i
want it um so guys please tell a friend
to tell a friend like subscribe and as
always chirp sitting in the comments uh
we're gonna need breeding grounds a lot
of people actually don't know what
chirps even means they found they do not
they actually don't because in the
comments they just butch up they're just
books
if you're not from the uk yeah i can
understand because uh someone some
someone from australia messaged us the
other week and was like i love the show
et cetera et cetera big man thing what
does chirps actually mean
because you just keep saying it chirps
means like what's the flirt flirt
with it crack on with the thing with it
yeah
you see a guy you see a girl you think
she's banging you move to her yeah
that's what chirpzin is that's what it
is you're spitting games yeah natural
instincts yeah
follow your gut exactly um that's what
chirps it is so church to sing in the
comments um
find a partner for the breeding grounds
white robes and yeezys
um that's the uniform 2023 a nice
log cabin in idaho
um is where we're going to be at guys so
cornered off yeah cornered off secular
from the world
um and then we're just going to
indoctrinate utes into our way of
thinking and no one gets cancelled over
there no one and everyone just bangs
bangs and laughs free reign yeah yeah
open bar zip zips on tap there's a life
over there there's a life over there
um so guys as always thank you for that
and if you're listening um to the smooth
mellow tones of your boy j money and
fire lord for eggs whether that be
spotify apple podcast google podcast
amazon music wherever it is you listen
to your podcast please please please
um subscribe to the channel and leave a
nice review it does wonders um for the
show starting yeah please please please
um it would mean a lot to us and uh
apart from that i think
i think we're good to go all righty then
all righty then okay cool so um before
we start well
to start um
i'm like a week behind now uh because of
our recording schedule but did you watch
the eddie hall versus thor fight no
you didn't miss much
to be fair you didn't miss the only
thing i saw was the
what's the thing they do beforehand the
little
oh like the um the comfort like the um
press conference press conference yeah
yeah i see eddie hall just
stand up
yeah trying to try to eggman on and
that's all i did i completely forgot
about fight after that yeah um
i don't know what i was expecting from
the fight before i wasn't expecting that
much um but obviously two of the
strongest men in the world
trying to swing bombs like this
intriguing too yeah that's intriguing to
anyone um
they can't box for [ __ ] it doesn't
surprise me but the thing is as well as
mad as well because i know
i think eddie might have had a couple of
fights already i'm not sure but thor's
definitely had a couple of fights okay
and that he's one i think okay um
also did you see him shredded down from
what he used to look like
they were wearing clothes like
their tops
so shredded now okay shredded okay um
but anyway so
it was all right i know a lot of people
loads of people messaged me over the
weekend saying oh you need to react to
the thought fight you need to react to
the eddie um eddie thor fight and i'm
just like all right cool man
and then i watched it and i was just
like i don't know what you want me to
say yeah um so
it was all right so obviously like i
said thought shredded down it looks
pretty [ __ ] decent to be fair i'm
sure he's still strong as tits he's tall
as anything eddie
looks slimmer but it's still carrying a
lot of weight
um
it was it was sold as the heaviest fight
or the heaviest boxing match of all time
or whatever whether or not that's true i
guess it technically has to be true they
are built pretty deep
yeah yeah yeah
but um yeah man it's one of them ones
where people say like oh you always
resort um
well
i don't even know what the terminology
is or the phrases but it's like you
always like resort to the the level of
your training so like if you're if
you're trained to a certain degree like
in in a like fight or flight scenario
you'll always resort to your training so
if your training is whack regardless of
how how much you're flaunting it in the
game like when you're scared you'll
resort to your training yeah yeah yeah
yeah and that happened with eddie
because i've seen some like pad work of
eddie before and and a lot of people
saying like this guy can actually for a
punch like he's looking a bit decent um
like his technique wasn't that bad from
the training videos and stuff that i saw
so i thought okay he could bring a
little something
and the fights that i've seen thor do
he he looks terrible so i was like okay
i think eddie might have him up
obviously there's a massive heightened
reach difference but i think eddie might
have him up because in the pad work he
looks a bit all right but um from what
i've seen with
his technique is terrible fam
flip-flop universe bollywood twist
[Laughter]
bollywood twist
oh you know reverse yeah yeah um eddie
was looking [ __ ] brav oh is it well i'll
tell you what it's like one of their
ones as well was like he was
how do i explain it you know when you're
playing like tekken or something and
you're on a buttermash thing and you
figure out one combo that moves and
that's all you use even when it don't
make sense anymore okay you're using it
because that's all you know okay and you
resorted back to his training yeah so
what he was doing was you come out in
the first round
thor don't know nothing but no one two
that's it okay one two that's all he
knows okay but one uh i think in the
second round he dropped eddie with that
backhand oh is it dropped him okay just
gave him a cap and then
there was a little gap between the arm
rocked his jaw dropped him on his arse
okay um because he's manager's too
strong what's the height difference oh
thor's tall family i don't think eddie's
sure eddie's not i've seen eddie before
he's not that short no he's taller than
you he's taller than me i'd say he's
like
off the dome i'd say he's probably six
six on the dot six maybe yeah um thor's
like
we're talking thor probably like six
seven six eight he's not he's like
seriously tall oh wow he's total oh wow
he might even be taller than that but
yeah he's tall bro he's at least six six
oh wow he's [ __ ] tall okay um so yeah
there's a massive height difference
between them man and
um rock daddy and i think that i want to
say second round uh might be wrong um
but what eddie was doing he had this
overhand right that was working for him
so what he would do it was he would
faint like a little jab
duck under whatever was retaliating and
throw
a right hand over the top yeah yeah yeah
connected like four times in like the
first round with that okay so in his
head he's like is his overhand right
working working yeah yeah fan but
so after the first round eddie was
shattered
shattered you could tell his feet
weren't moving right and basically what
he'd done is he would drop his left hand
and he literally would arch himself like
literally side on okay and was basically
egging thought to come on a thing but
his hand was literally cocked he's
waiting for that it was the most obvious
ploy you've ever seen his hand was
literally cocked already yeah while he's
edger he's literally doing this
edging up next to him with his hand
ready like say man's gonna fall for that
so the thought would just give him a
little
just pepper him up a little bit and then
every time he'll get the chance he'd
throw this slow
massive haymaker overhand right and
thought would just like step back
just
just move the [ __ ] out the way and then
he was like
ah shattered and then same thing again
that shoulder just bump in fam it was
embarrassing what was the purpose of
this fight
cash
cash and clout cash and clout that's
literally all it was was it was it
instigated by fans i don't know who fam
i'll be honest with you asking for
history i don't know who the [ __ ]
instigated it because i'm thinking this
is not
obviously we've spoken in the past about
like um
uh creators going and doing boxing and
stuff but these are actual
quote-unquote bodybuilders and blah blah
why why are they what's this all about i
don't know what the purpose is bro i
think it's just beef between them two
and they're just going to box it out i
think that's just that seems to be the
celebrity way to resolve anything these
days yeah but have a box um who said
they've got cash for putin
um to have a fight who was it elon
elon musk
said square up square up russia i've got
cash for ukraine me versus you square up
and i was like fair enough
did he offer up cash because i know he
was asking
ukraine to offer he was asking putin to
offer up ukraine no yeah he was saying
lao ukraine yeah i don't know but what i
didn't know what his his what he was
bringing together
to be i have no idea if putin's
responding up i'm pretty sure i know i
don't obviously
yeah he's not playing that's silly but
yeah i know all i know all i know is
that i saw someone offering up putin for
cash on a one-on-one square up table
yeah so yeah elon musk i know came out
and was like
let's just have it out ourselves
man to man um
i'm not gonna lie i think putin will
smack the [ __ ] out of here i think poop
will smack the shower a lot of people
i love p1a i have no idea you know
he's not just face
he's got training behind those eyes oh
yeah yeah he's because he's got i know
he's got black belt in judo and tae kwon
do that doesn't i didn't never knew that
but that doesn't surprise me fam he just
always looks focused yeah
he looks like he he knows what his
peripherals saying yeah i mean word on
the street is they give anyone a black
bear and taekwondo
that's what i heard okay word on the
street
they get very toxic in harry potter
um judo is a different [ __ ]
yeah that's a different [ __ ] okay so
that's no you don't [ __ ] around if he
gets hands on yeah it's long
he's gonna fling you yes get off yeah
yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah but that being
said he's an old [ __ ] as well so yeah
this is why i couldn't be a political
leader
because no i i no one's sending for me
on a one-on-one screen because i'll if i
yeah if i was boris if i was in a g4
team whatever it is yeah yeah i'm
sending for anyone on a scrap team
that's how i would resolve all my all
beef yeah fight me yeah if i'm fighting
for a country yeah
i'm not losing right i'll play dirty
i'll play dirt you have to fight me 100
you have to fight me and we'll see he's
really going to win yeah and that's the
thing i would be terrible as well
because like it's not in putin's best
interest to scrap elon musk it means
nothing but like it better bet a better
is a baby i bet it's a bet if it must
trumps him yeah if it's wrong yeah
that's what i'm saying so but the thing
is well my pride if i was putin i
probably wouldn't let me not take that
fight of course of course it's some
random billionaires like pussyo
la i'll fight you and if you lose you
have to lock ukraine off
and if you win
there's an extra 50 billion in your
account tomorrow i'll say yeah
say less set up time and place time time
and time time and place time that's all
i i won't even at him i'll just tweet
from putin's account time and place
i won't even musk i won't at musk at all
just time everyone knows what one time
and place wink face
that's it a young tnp that's it wink
emoji
that's time and place time and place
that's the thing right say up this is
i'm telling you bro
i'm telling you this is what i'm saying
bro like
this is why i couldn't be a political
leader because no one's sending for me
on twitter saying time and place
yeah let's go ego let's go
this is what i said about the youtube
boxing thing yes i'll end up pulling out
on the day yeah because my ego would
sign up to whatever
and my ego is as soon as someone calls
me a [ __ ] of some description yeah
let's go let's go let's literally have
it out
um but yeah i don't know what elon musk
is thinking because he'll just rock up
there and be
his bank account will get dried out i
don't know i don't know why continue
have him in a chokehold bro these
russians they they grow up different
they do i don't think certain man
understands these russians grow up
different bro you fight with bears and
[ __ ] yeah they just wrestle anyone
they're different out there yeah they
got a they got a martial art style out
there called [ __ ] okay
really yeah it's not on really yeah it's
like a
it's like
kickboxing meets judo okay
so there it is basically just mma yeah
kickboxing means judo meets wrestling
yeah like it's just it is it's it's long
it's long and whenever
like russians dagestanians make their
way into the ufc they just chop it up
it's light for them fair enough so it's
yeah i wouldn't be centered for putting
on a scrap thing if i'm in that age
bracket
the ukrainian president on the other
hand is a young buck yeah he's he's on
stuff he's odd scrap poo sure is
straight away
isn't it vladimir putin vladimir putin
um who's the bro who's the boss
klitschko isn't it click click close
brother that's oh no he's the mayor or
something
like that
yeah the president brother i'm sure he
would used to be like a stand-up
comedian or something oh is he yeah he's
like a media personality okay that just
swung the votes okay and then he got in
power
and then it all kicked off
i was [ __ ] bricks
now he's now he's the brother of the
joker yeah yeah
but yeah he's been holding his own boy
yeah yeah but if i was him i'm i'm
sending for a scrap
because i'm sure growing up in ukraine
ain't easy of course not yeah you learn
some stuff
you learn stuff not by a choice yeah not
by choice whatsoever speak enough to be
fair
um fam
binge top boy over the weekend really
the new season
okay
um i've not started it at all but i've
seen a lot of um tweets and blah blah
blah about how people have binged it and
tried to spoil it on twitter or socials
and blah blah blah i'm like
and it's like i saw i saw a tweet that
said uh i met kaina white some event and
blah blah and he said to know
i watched the whole thing in 24 hours
and kenya responded something along the
lines of i'm paraphrasing obviously
something along the lines of we spent
three or four months or x amount of
months filming this filming the show for
you to watch in 24 hours mug
mug citing along those lines you know i
dare can't understand
because i binged it unless
i dare him to call me a mug for it
because you've got me hooked by the
zinger i'm the mug
nah i've heard it i've heard it's good
i've i've heard also heard that some of
the accent isn't that great oh some of
it's poor but
i watched the trailer not too long ago
and it does look very juicy it does look
very good because i really really
enjoyed it yeah so i'm not going to like
a few of the smaller rolls yeah some of
the acting's on like a a gcc drama thing
i'm just going to see
i don't want to be rude and i'm not
going to point fingers
but some of the smaller roles
the budget was a bit sort of your
seating gcse drama
a young year 10 yeah as well yeah i'm
not going to lie i'm not even saying
you're 11. you're 10. oh wow fam yeah
i'm not gonna lie bro
but
the the thing as a whole was live but
yeah i'm not gonna lie some of the small
roles yeah yeah yeah yeah budget wasn't
budgeting would you say it was better
than the first um
yeah
good question thing is i always struggle
with first i i mean like the previous
yeah yeah the previous season not like
the first first first first
i loved the first place
yeah i really the first first top one
was up i really enjoyed the first year
yeah i did what was it one two or two
seasons did it happen
i don't remember i think it was two but
it was on channel four yeah it was
banging yeah but yeah last season was
still [ __ ] banging as well this
season popped uh would i say it's better
than last season i'm trying to even
remember last season now
uh a little bit some bob's not gonna
last season was pretty live to be fair
to be fair there's a couple bollywood
twists in here that
were popping oh is it because they were
coming at different angles because
obviously last year's travel to another
cup
last season the main thing was just this
beef yeah yeah between the shayna yeah
yeah that was just that was the whole
basically the whole plot
um this one fam
there's angle it's like um it's like um
ozark season four in terms of like the
new family and all that stuff yeah
there's yeah yeah yeah yeah there's
addition [ __ ] angles in this one okay
so to be fair this season's probably
better okay this is probably better they
had to step yeah they had to step it up
and uh they they came through binged it
bro
binged
eggs turn up so eight yeps eight x yeah
um i'm i'm pretty certain i might just
have to be on a roman team from nowhere
you know
i'm just gonna throw it out there
i know i think they're trying to deter
man from the roadman life but it just
seems appealing
[Laughter]
do you tell brother
without giving much away i'm not going
to say any spoilers but there's just
certain aspects that seem appealing to
me yeah yeah yeah i don't know um i mean
there's a couple bits where men get
their head literally kicked in yeah
which i'm not really feeling but
duchenne's crew don't seem to lose a
scrap yeah so if i could roll with that
man
i might be all right yeah yeah as long
as i'm not bottom barrel yeah yeah
because they've got the bottom barrel
crackheads yeah and they get smacked
about by every time they came out if i
can be up where like lieutenant like
where jack's at yeah yeah well there's
somewhere around about where jackson
yeah that's that like i'm i'm boss i'm
like middle management
i'm making enough p
but i'm not literally packing
food in you're not a runner yeah i'm not
a pro
no you're far from a right yeah yeah
yeah and i'm not i'm not i don't have to
sit in the market for 19 hours a day if
i don't want to because it looks
freezing and frankly quite uncomfortable
and then i don't know if these men are
allowed to leave their post or what or
scanner i don't know if there's food
breaks yeah who's changing shifts yeah i
don't know they don't explain it
properly so all that is long yeah but
the whole um
yeah i just want to be mouthy in it and
i just want to tamper bread up a couple
times
just like yeah yeah i want to be on the
detective things yeah whenever my like
ah i heard this brother from north is
chat and pop
find him yeah
and then i tell
i come to the use yeah and i'm like this
is the brother we're looking for yeah
find him yeah and then someone comes
back and said ah hey i heard he's at
shrubs and peckham yeah and i just rock
up with the the man and i throw the
first blow and i'm like [ __ ]
and then i'm out
in scene
that's my role in tea yeah that's what i
want and i make cake
and then all i do is complain to
duchesne
[Laughter]
like the youngers are starving yeah yeah
that's that's what i want to be having
more for you
we need more food what's going on with
this connect
where's the grub
we need more food in the streets the
youngers are balling
that's my
role that's hilarious
guys we're just gonna take a very very
quick break from the episode to shed
some love over to our boys at manscape
guys so you already know spring has
sprung and we're doing the spring
cleaning we're all about the spring
cleaning um this year guys and to
complete your grooming game this spring
you need the new refined cologne
signature scent by landscapes that's
signature sense these men are doing bits
and bobs yeah bits and bobs that
signature scent bro this stuff is legit
and what have you smelling like royalty
that monarchy scent you can't just buy
that anywhere monarchy scent you can't
yeah it's a tough nut to crack it's
different but your boys over at manscape
they've cracked the code go and get that
royalty sent um and if you purchase now
you'll receive two free gifts you're
gonna get the performance boxer briefs
that we never shut up about performance
boxer briefs and the shed travel bag
when you get the performance package 4.0
join the gazillion men worldwide that
benefited from your boys at manscaped
smell and feel good this spring guys and
all you need to do is head on over to
manscaped.com
the code is sng sierra november golf
thank you sir and that's going to get
you 20 off and free shipping guys one
more time for the people in the back
it's manscape.com you need to use the
code s n g sierra november gold come on
and that's twenty percent off and free
shipping let's get back to the episode
thank you very much thank you
yeah i said the road life is for me you
know
that's [ __ ] hilarious yeah if i'm
good something i'm not gonna lie some of
it looks juicy yeah because they're
always
it's always zero to ten yeah i don't
know what their tuesday wednesdays look
like
but fam like one drop of a hat is it's
life or death yeah because these men run
up with guns
these men are running up to a gun fight
at like six hours notice
like i need two weeks yeah yeah i need
to prepare things
there's there's scenes in there where
amanda's like
ballies and straps tonight
i've got a link
i just look at what i've got i've got a
nando's date in three hours time
man said bellies and straps burner
phones only from now
[ __ ] now it's it's stressful fam you
have to be on job
[ __ ] you've got to be on drugs you have
to be willing to throw it all away at
yeah yeah yeah for what cash in hand
nah fam tax freedom tax it's tax free
but you can't do [ __ ] yeah yeah you
gotta wash that
yeah yeah you actually have to wash it
and that's when tax comes in play
if you're watching p you have to tax it
it's long
fine it's all long but yeah juicy show
okay i'm a binge not this week probably
i'm busy this week probably next week
mm-hmm i was i was next door because i
didn't even want to [ __ ] binge it i
only binged it because um
i was
hung over on saturday yeah went out my
boy on friday
hung over on saturday
um
and
i got in bed at 8 00 pm
i was like i'm done with this day yeah
eight i was so just dead i'm done with
this day got in bed put on netflix and
it was either top boy
or drive to survive
oh and i was literally
i had my remote flicking between the two
i didn't know what to put and in my head
i thought
top boy is going to be a more mellow
thing for me because drive to survive is
is [ __ ] adrenaline
yeah and i just haven't got the
emotional capacity to deal with it not
today not not today um
so yeah i put on top boy thinking i'll
watch one episode maybe two be asleep by
10.
i was up at like 132.
i was deep i was deep
it sucked you weird [ __ ]
speaking of um
speaking of f1 um did you like watch the
highlights of this race gone last
weekend nah i've seen nothing okay so i
where you up to on drive to survive
season four if i haven't started it but
i was like what i'm saying i was even
gonna start it
i thought you were you had started
i started so it's intense but i don't
want to give away too many spoilers
because
obviously this new season 2022
certain drivers have changed from this
current season four
which i only found out by watching the
highlights of this yeah yeah
but all i'm gonna say
is ferrari and red bull
in these 2021 2022 bahrain highlights
not even a murky thing fam neck and neck
bro not even a sadie fam hamilton
hamilton had to scrap
hamilton had to fight his way through
that's all i'm gonna say say less that's
all i'm going to say i'm going to catch
up on drive to survive and the current
goings on
this
it's juicy
the thing is i am actually so gassed
that one you recommended the show to me
to i've actually started to like get a
deep dive into what f1 is about yeah
yeah
three months ago you could have asked me
name three things about f1 all i would
say is literally f1 i found you know i
wouldn't know anything else and that's
two things you know my um yeah sorry
scott yeah my stepdad used to love f1
and i he used to put it on on a sunday
and whatever he's like this is boring
bro boring cares about cars racing
bro bro
after changed everything after watching
this netflix show it's changed the whole
game and it's also because everyone
knows i'm an avid
football fan and united fan so when the
season's on i just love watching
football as much as i can but when the
season's off there's no other sport that
interests me yeah i don't watch boxing
that much i don't watch maybe some
basketball yes but everything else is
just not really entertaining for me and
the basketball is at dick at the clock
because
i only watch i haven't watched a live
nba game in probably the last two three
years you know i mean
tennis for me isn't as juicy as it was
when we used to watch it when we watched
tennis in uni i don't know why
it was just juicy because we had [ __ ]
all else to do it was just that was it
we had focal let's do but it was empty
it was banging it was entertaining but
now even just watching the highlights
made me feel i want to watch all 57 laps
brother yeah yeah i want to watch all 57
laps yeah because i need to see the
scraps yeah oh it's nice juicy all right
the highlights alone yeah between um
ferrari and red bull wow wow
these mom were going at it do you know
who won have you seen anything about who
i've seen nothing oh wow okay okay i saw
it all over socials yeah
okay i saw it all over somebody nothing
of this season i've seen a couple memes
about mercedes yeah yeah yeah but that's
it uh hamilton had to scrap oh say less
yeah yeah he's a fighter he is a fighter
i'm not gonna lie my whole life i
thought he was a giant [ __ ]
i knew nothing about him to have any
judgments yeah i just thought he was
killing it i knew nothing about him yeah
i just thought it was a [ __ ] okay i
don't know why i thought that yeah yeah
i just did he's oh yeah he's he scraps
yeah
that's what he needs to do at certain
points get him on the track he's ready
to go ready bro
ready but yeah it's um
it's gonna be a good season i can tell i
don't know where they're at this weekend
i'm not too sure but it was bahrain
first opening week was bahrain and you
look good look juicy look juicy so yeah
i'm saying less i'm looking forward to
this week all right as of this week yeah
bingeing drive to survive catching up
with this season catch up bro i watched
i watched two apps on the way down here
i'm gonna watch the rest on the way back
up gang juicy bro gang gag again
um you said you had a little topic yes
so it's
somewhat a fun fact slash
topic that i want to discuss so have you
heard of
this leah thomas chick that's been going
around on socials
no i take it by the look of your face
again maybe it's names bro i don't know
names but anyway carry on so leah thomas
is
a is the first
trans transgender athlete to win uh ncaa
divisions in any sport she's a swimmer
you've seen this thing i know all about
this bro
so obviously she she tried she's been
breaking records sam she was like
when she was a guy
he was ranked 430 something or whatever
yeah saturn [ __ ] something crazy
now
she identifies as a woman she's first
and it's like
how are people how are we getting away
with this
how are the officials letting this
happen it's a i understand identity i
understand
you wanna
you feel as if you're not the person you
don't have the
you are not in the body you want to be
in you want to change all of that i
understand but i feel like
it's
it's unfair it 100 is unfair you have
muscular advantages you have height
advantages you still have these male
things inside you that make you a
stronger swimmer
right like it's it's sorry to cut you
off there's there's this there was this
um track and field athlete a few years
ago i can't remember her name
um black chick
but she's testosterone the testosterone
chick
but everyone thought she was a man
yeah she ran a man where she just had
like
genetically she was just
she just runs bro yeah but they made a
rule i can't remember what it was
they
basically told her you need i can't
remember is either it was one way or the
other i'm so lost with that story
because it was like a year or two maybe
yeah maybe two yeah maybe two something
along the lines she had to take
testosterone
like
um suppressants
to get a testosterone down
um so it could be level with everyone
yeah blah blah blah i'm sure they might
have even increased
the
um
the levels or like the optimum like the
uh top line level
of what a woman
um
athlete is allowed to have in terms of
testosterone they may have even
increased that for the division i don't
i can't remember i might be making that
up but i feel like that was a ting so
basically yeah she had to bring her
testosterone down and they might have
actually just brought the whole level as
a whole up so a couple men are allowed
to
but yeah my stance is very easy with the
the transgender argument because it's
it's not even just with this swimming
thing it's been happening in sports all
over yeah yeah yeah um with transgen
transgender athletes and it's like um
there's even like an mma fighter that's
trans that's just tamping [ __ ] up
is it yeah and i think it needs to be
it's very easily like dealt i say easily
putting
people's feelings about stuff aside is
very easily dealt with
you either
like it's one of them things it's like
um
there you never used to because i know
one of the arguments is like oh you just
bring in a transgender division
and it's like
their main argument to that is like for
one
which is a little bit more political is
the whole well trans women are real
women so they need to go in the women's
division
however this is just like i don't like
ignoring plain obvious facts like you
said
they have body advantages that's just a
fact that that will always be yeah if
they don't want to compete with the men
because i'm sure again they would have
taken estrogen so they probably have
less testosterone than the menstrual
they might not fit even with the men's
category anymore just make you just make
a transgender category and it's
patterned and i know a lot of the
argument i've heard around that in
articles and stuff is like oh but that's
like
there's there aren't enough athletes for
that and it's like cool well there never
used to be enough women athletes there
never used to be women leagues in
anything they never used to be
the paralympics never used to be a thing
there never used to be enough disabled
people for these things but now once it
once it's formed
there is there is yeah so you just need
to form it form it and then we go from
there and it might be a bit boring at
the start there might be only a few
people to start with but i'm sure as the
years go on it will pattern up it would
encourage more people and it will
encourage more people because like you
said like
a lot of i think a lot of the
controversy around it is that people
seem to be very scared to say this ain't
right and everyone keeps saying this is
fine this is fine when it's very
obviously not fine and even uh i know
like a lot of her teammates are very
much like yeah it's fine but then i've
heard like behind closed doors they're
like it's it can't run like it's very
obvious he can't run and it has nothing
to do with being transphobic or anything
like that it's just a simple fact bro
like
you're built different literally
literally built you're literally built
different things it makes no sense
that's it it's not fair yeah the fact
that
obviously leah thomas is winning these
events and she's getting these medals or
whatever it's like
after the race she like shook high five
the other two competitors that came
second and third is like if i'm coming
second or third as a woman in this is
this event i'm vexed
especially if i'm coming second
by by like five six meters because
you're obviously built different yeah
you'll feel different and that's fine
and then i think that i guess the other
argument is is okay cool so my one
stance is cool either make a transgender
league mm-hmm 100 which i agree on let
me take all the steroids i want
make it fair yeah make it fair because
there's no other way there's literally
no other way you can work all the
steroids i want and then we can pattern
up
we can go the steroids that's the only
way
it yeah but it's it's a tough old gig oh
bro it is it's gonna come to a it's
coming to a i think in the next couple
years it's gonna come to a head where
people just make a decision once and for
all because it can't just keep it keeps
spiraling out of control and there's too
many of these stories of
there's like i've heard weightlifting
stories i've heard mma stories i've
heard now swimming stories of like yeah
like transgender athletes
just smashing the records
especially when they were very mediocre
athletes in male categories
they're smashing records in female
categories
and it's just like okay cool what of
course it needs to be sorted yeah it's
it's tough
anyway anyway uh on the lighter note
what have we got twitter hall of fame
before we get to the hall of fame i've
got a quick um
you know when i told you before like
sometimes when i watch shows that um
bella recommends all of us on bella's
algorithm is somewhat kind of pops
yeah yeah we spoke about it before a few
is that where you found good girls
no i got good girls from another person
from a different recommendation oh okay
cool but good girls pops i've nearly
finished that show
so have you ever heard of a medium
called tyler henry
medium is like a spiritual yes yes yes
yes oh
i don't know maybe i never have where
they're from uk uh america america
i don't i don't think so i think they're
booked from kelly because it's the
show's more time based around caddy um
anyway so the basis or the crux of the
show is he's a medium he he has um he's
gay i don't know if that's relevant um
he's got a partner he's got um his mom
is his assistant slash driver and so is
his sister as well
every
every um
client he has he doesn't know about
prior so he gets the information the
producers get the information the
producers tell the drive is i his mom or
his sister or his boyfriend whoever
takes him to the spot
and he kind of gets like readings on
what he's going to be reading that day
for example um
he meant to he went to meet um
the
current owner of l.a lakers
i think her name is jeannie genie
jeannie russell jd bust something like
that um and she had
she was having like not necessarily the
premonitions but she was having um
certain feelings about wondering whether
her dad is um proud of her and blah blah
because her dad was the owner of the
lakers got passed on to her blah blah
blah so he's going back and forth with
this whole medium thing about
trying to connect with
the father and explaining everything to
her but they don't give anything away so
let's say
let's say i'm tired for example and
you're my client i would be like
i'm getting this feeling of x y and z
blah blah blah does this ring about
he'll be reeling off a few things and
the reaction they give is like [ __ ] i
was spot on a spot on his spot in a spot
and obviously he has no idea about
anything that you want to discuss today
he just knows that he's getting these
readings and getting his feelings but
the reason why i want to talk about this
show isn't because of the actual medium
it's because of the actual backstory but
i'm just giving you a bit of background
of what the show is and what he does
okay that's the reason why i was going
through that point okay but it's kind of
like a it's kind of like a
the show in a sense has a bollywood
twist because
it's a show about this medium thing but
it's also a [ __ ] documentary because
his
mum
the backstory of his mom is that his mum
he thought his mum was adopted
comes to find out his mum was taken
fam when when she was a youth just taken
by a camera and her name is stella
her name is [ __ ] stash she got
[ __ ] taken and she has brothers and
sisters
but her brother and sister stella's what
not stella i can't remember my mum's
name let's let's call the mom amy amy's
white or like very very fair-skinned and
the brother and sister
i want to say is
latin america i don't know where but
very much latin america is evident but
the kids at the time
didn't know anything about it because
stella the mum at the time said she was
dating a white man so they just thought
you know x and y equals zed
boom
little did they know
she got yanks i still don't know how and
why and blah blah i've not gone that far
into it
um
back in the day she ai stella was at a
hotel with the kids so there's three
kids um two one guy and two girls
including quote unquote amy tyler's mum
and this is way before obviously tyler
was born um
he
she um she hollered the son i can't
remember his name she holded her son and
said come to
come to the hotel that where um that i'm
at i want to show you
something he comes through two [ __ ]
dead bodies
he she has killed the owners of this
hotel and convinced the sun to bury
these bodies
he's 18 thinking what the [ __ ] he just
wanted to be a happles happy living
civil servant he wants to be a police
officer he wants to have a family he
just wants to retire
let me pause you there yeah i'm lost and
i'm confused right
right i'm so sorry hit me hit me i'm so
confused hit me where are you confused
i'll right i'll
okay
we're calling stella tyler's mom
no no no stella is the grandma stella's
tyler's mom amy is tyler's mom i can't
remember her name but let's say her name
is amy yeah okay so tyler
there's amy
amy's brother and sister when they're
like 18. yeah so they were huge so
stella's the youngest because when you
said yout i was thinking like six seven
no no no when you said she bailed the
sun he's only 18. i think
i don't know what's going on
hotel owners
tell me i i'm so confused just tell me
i'm trying to tell you bro i'm trying to
tell you right okay so let me just take
this
let me
yeah
back in the day yeah stella's stella's
top dog she's stella's the the the head
of the household yes she's got three
kids yes one's a boy and two are girls
two are girls one girl is tyler's mum
yes who's white who first
okay cool okay cool now she's there
they're in a hotel room yes with the two
daughters
she no stella's in a hotel and she calls
her son cool
because she says i want to show you
something he comes there and the owners
of the hotel are dead in her room yeah
cool dead in a spot he doesn't say we're
just dead in a spot in a hotel cool
she then convinces him to drag
the bodies and bury the bodies they
obviously go to pen
the grandma and uh
stella stella and the son go to pen
amy's brother amy's
brother pen amy's rougher sweetie i
don't know why go to pen
obviously this is all before tyler's
born yeah yeah so it's only when let's
say stella was no let's say amy was 55
for example it was only at that age she
realized
her brother and sister aren't her
brother and sister
because they've done a they've done a um
um
they've done one of them things yeah and
if it pans out they're not even related
so obviously tyler being a medium
has like i need to find answers i need
to find [ __ ] answers so it's all
unraveling like a [ __ ] documentary
regardless of this toileting tyler's got
his own show trying to speak to dead man
yeah and trying to get dead man to
comfort other man but he's also trying
to find out the mystery of his family
the mystery of his whole family is all
convoluted bro so it's bringing us back
to the snatching who got snatched
tyler's mum amy got snatched from when
we don't know brother but how does she
know that she got snatched because
they're not related
they're not she they just came back one
day with a you she came back one day
just for you so her mom's a [ __ ]
murderer mom's a murderer and cracked
and she's stealing you she just took a
you we don't know how we don't know why
okay do you know what i mean i'm with
you so at the time that when when i say
the when i say the brother and sister
didn't question it because at the time
she was dating a white stella was dating
a white man oh so it just seemed as if
okay she's fair didn't even clock that
she wasn't ever pregnant or nothing
she just snatched to you she just she
left and came back and she would she
just had a you
a baby she just had a you
nah nah nah
this is what obviously i'm okay i'm so
far behind i don't know what the [ __ ] is
the name of this show it's called
life after death with tyler henry
okay cool
okay cool thank you fam because what i'm
gonna say to you
is when you started chatting about
mediums
and lakers owners
and he's answering questions that she
didn't even ask
i wanted to smack you and say you've
fell off
you've
fell off when it comes to
recommendations there's no way in hell
my
lifelong friend
is recommending a [ __ ] medium show to
me
about some [ __ ] in l.a
but now you've you've come with this
bollywood twist i told you the show for
some reason has a bollywood twist
unwarranted bollywood all right sound
sound sounds i'm not i'm not saying it
as a recommendation you're just saying
i'm just saying it because you watch one
bella's algorithm and this is why i'm
currently uh this is why company
watching and it's like raw that's wild
there's some wild twists in this [ __ ]
that is [ __ ] wild because i i
literally never expected it oh i
literally never i didn't expect it when
you were telling the story famous nuts
yeah there's a story he tells
there's a story that one of the
clients tells tyler
um
it made
what's the word it resonated a lot more
with tyler because he never really gets
emotionally invested in in his readings
he just does the readings
um so if it's like a mother that's lost
a son or blah blah it never really
affects him because he doesn't have a
kid he's never going to feel it in that
way he feels sympathy not empathy if
that makes sense
um
but there was a client he had the client
was also gay
he had a boyfriend
and for some weird reason this is the
story that they said this is not my
words and for some weird reason
the boyfriend said they were at beach
and the boyfriend said
oh my god someone's coming to get me so
he must have had been feeling these like
spiritual awakenings or premonitions or
whatever oh my god someone's coming to
get me
and then for some reason there was a
gust of wind
and the
you know those beach umbrellas
that people have
a beach umbrella blew and pierced the
boyfriend through the skull
on the show this happened no no no it
didn't they didn't show it this was the
story the my man told tyler okay
so he while he said in this story he
said
he was having random thoughts and he
said out loud
someone's coming to get me and then
what's it called like a canopy i don't
know why school but yeah popped his
boyfriend in the skull
bro that's one of the weirdest stories
i've ever heard
weirdest stories i've ever heard
fair play all right man but yeah that
was that just wanted to let you know
give you a little deep dive on what i'm
watching at a moment what i've what i've
jumped on because of bella's algorithm
but
twitter hall of fame is what we will do
all right game it's due to a hall of
fame
[Music]
[ __ ] get a macbook and never
use the word laptop again
bro bougie apple products will change
your integrity it will it will it will
change your integrity
i see even till date like um i see
instagram stories and you can just
obviously tell when i said android it
just [ __ ] me off i feel like android
users can't tell
the difference when they look at stories
yeah yeah it's like um yeah it's like uh
i remember people used to send me like
android emojis and i used to see him
think yuck what the [ __ ] is that
it's this i'm pixelated emoji thing yeah
move from me it's like and you'd send
them an iphone one and they'd be like
it's just questions question one yeah
question marks dead like you need to do
better you really need to do better
just because i said i don't go for looks
doesn't mean you should look like a
weapon formed against me
wow jesus christ
at the gym where's the hype machine at
the stop
oh fam
if there was a hype machine in the gym i
would use it three times a day
where was i where the [ __ ] was i
i can't remember um
oh my god yes i remember fam
i'm literally just not tall enough and
it's just not on
because i think because we play averages
we don't play averages but we talk about
averages i'm pretty sure
okay i'm gonna google it right now what
is uk average male height bro because i
think i'm above average
it's five nine i think that's what they
say bro that's what yeah i'm good at
what they say
average height uk male average height
five nine five so that's you in it fam
so i'm supposed to be um
two inches above average your boy's
sitting pretty at five eleven they don't
feel like it for that they don't feel
like it bro when i went to this um so i
went to the the moonlight premiere with
jay the other day
and they had to do some uh paparazzi
thing okay um on the steps it was at the
great british museum i said it was on
the steps okay and they were like cool
stand on the steps
i found no word of a like i looked like
some make-a-wish kid next to my man how
old was he six four six four yeah
he was towering over me and then to mug
me off even more he put his arm around
me like a yacht like a little boy yeah
who had of course he would do that
and he kept the whole time yeah he was
like i'm sorry bro i'm sorry you're not
sorry
i said get off me
he's looking at me i'm looking at him
i've never felt so small in my life bro
there's literally nothing physically an
emotion
and i'm like i'm just not tall enough
yeah there's nothing we could do about
it nothing
nothing there literally isn't bro
nothing you guys can get this bbl this
tummy tuck thing there's nothing we can
do there's nothing unless i'm willing to
let a doctor
shave my leg off yeah and then put satin
in there some stilting in the shin
i'm done i'm just done at it and it's
just bro it's just painful man it
literally is painful bro
it's just i'm not i don't consider
myself a short person by any means yeah
until i see a tall brother yeah yeah and
i'm like what is it i shouldn't ever
have to do this for another guy or
another man
we're supposed to be equals
nah brav it's peak oh it's hilarious i'm
sick of it man uh um
but yeah the bane of me
is the game is the game and the game
literally is the game there's literally
nothing to do about it
yeah man yeah it's essentially to be
fair yeah um just before you carry on it
reminds me of you you know when i was
talking about my first sight yes i said
the guy there's a guy in there called
brent um
i said he's the buffett's guy i have
like white white guy you see yeah
i've seen yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah like
physically yeah and then when he was at
the uh altar yes when they had their
first idinapa or whatever and it's the
first time that the chicks have seen
the guys who is not their husband
one of the girls goes to his wife his
wife's called tamara one of his girls
goes to his wife ah
when you saw him at the altar but you're
thinking yes
yes she goes
to be fair i thought he was a bit short
that's the first thing she thought he's
a bit short and to be fair he is
because like he doesn't look because
he's taller than her
when you only ever see them two together
of course you have no idea that you're
sure yeah until it's a dinner party and
all the man's come in and he he's just
down here and you're like ah
that
looks brutal
and you're above this guy i've seen
brother
and you have to live like this it's just
not on bro it's not anyway right yeah so
back to the hall of fame
um
i really don't even like my girl i just
don't want to start over respectfully
[Music]
i know you're fair people to be fair
there's more women that go through that
than men tough i would say a strong 65
of women
ah
right this one is uh
this one is a um how do i say it
it's a tweet with a picture with a
caption all right so
i've been waiting so this girl tweeted
been waiting to use that line on a
[ __ ] and she put like a
cheeky emoji on her cool face
so the brother said
lol in caps you're so funny you know
and then she replied
i made you giggle baby girl x
yo
his fam his face would drop drop
drop what can you even reply to that
it's ruined my whole day
it's going to be one of them ones where
your initial reactions be like what the
[ __ ] yeah all right let me calm down let
me calm down let me [ __ ] calm down
because so
in her mind all she sees is three dots
and then
and then three dots again she's
wonderful
oh babe she's won the whole ticket i'm
vex about it yeah livid i'm vex about it
oh [ __ ] sake
let me calm down let me calm down
resonate with me
that's jokes oh
we're not gonna put we're not gonna
pretend like pete getting multiple
tattoos for someone he's been dating for
six months is normal
you've seen this thing about
so pete apparently got um i'll see pete
davidson got a tattoo
you say it was a tattoo
she called it a um she didn't call it a
tattoo she called it something else
but long story short pete davis got a
tattoo of something
to do with kim on him
like not too long ago and i don't know
why it was good she didn't call it
attached to this i know it's a slag tag
or something i don't know where he said
it was sad but yeah it's it's wild yeah
he's not normal though i don't know why
he's not normal at all that doesn't even
surprise me it's not normal at all but
anyway
this will probably resonate with you
because you've seen it um you've seen
the season
kano's the type of man you make food for
four times a day
random in that show you don't know where
you stand with kano
you don't know where you stand with him
you don't know if you're boys or not
he just keeps everyone on edge yeah yeah
the time
it's oh it's so straight i couldn't be
his boy and actually it's just so
stressful i'm looking forward to
watching it mom
oh [ __ ] it out who's buying these boiled
eggs as their snack in the tesco meal
deals please own up we need to chat i
saw that on twitter i literally saw that
on twitter the other day sweeted me is
[ __ ] facts who the [ __ ] is buying
those eggs
it's weird yuck
this is a um this is a chick
i was in the gym the other day and the
man asked me how many sets have i got
left
and i really didn't know what i did
really don't get the workout lingo so i
said
give me three minutes please i was so
embarrassed
oh that's funny a lot of one take me
back to the first day we met so i can
ghost you
tough
tough
my toxic trait is i'm psychic and i know
what you did because i just know
fam does every woman as every woman on
planet earth
are so frustrated this intuition team
shut up
the day i found out 51 was divisible by
17 was the day i knew anything was
possible in life
i checked it i read that tweet and
checked it
today
it checks it immediately
it's three yeah the answer is three wow
okay cool
[ __ ] girls think a baby is going to
change a man now her and the baby are
crying
[Laughter]
if i fall in love with you please don't
cheat on please don't cheat or put me in
a situation where i've got to step out
of character because i'm going to show
you some colors you ain't never seen in
a crayon box before
oh my days
all right this is the last one this is a
conversation as opposed to a tweet all
right cool um
dude you're never coming on my back
again
i had to wash my weave twice [ __ ]
girl
you've got the wrong number
wow
he knotted in my hair and gave me a fake
number i'm so sorry these dudes are
trash
oh
imagine i could never imagine that's not
something i could imagine i'd be human
i'd be fuming
i'll be fuming brother that's tough man
it is
oh well
um
that was
a lot of fun actually it was thank you
guys um
as always
head on over to patreon.com for our
shits gigs and we'll jump back in on
thursday guys um
please like comment subscribe church
sing in the comments lee review if
you're listening on the audio
um and as always guys love love love
[Music]